es un rechazo generalizado de los países
con gobiernos de izquierda en América
Latina hacia el gobierno de transición
de Perú presidido por Dina boluarte el
último roce diplomático fue con Colombia
tras que el congreso peruano declarara
persona no grata al presidente Gustavo
Petro por criticar la acción policial
contra los manifestantes
el Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
toma nota de la moción del Congreso de
la República de Perú interpreta que es
un acto de carácter político al órgano
legislativo de Perú que no compromete al
pueblo y por tanto no afecta la
histórica relación con la hermana nación
Asimismo reitera su confianza en que la
democracia y el estado de derecho se
impondrán en el Perú pero este no ha
sido el único desencuentro del ejecutivo
de boluarte con naciones de izquierda
México Bolivia Argentina o chile han
cuestionado el encarcelamiento del
presidente Pedro castillo y la represión
policial en las protestas de las últimas
semanas motivo por el que el presidente
de México Andrés Manuel López Obrador se
negó a entregar la presidencia rotativa
de la alianza del Pacífico a Perú le voy
a dar instrucciones al secretario de
relaciones exteriores que le notifique
este
a los miembros
del grupo de Río qué hacemos
porque yo no quiero entregar
este a un gobierno
que considero espurio Bolivia llegó a
publicar un comunicado conjunto con
México Colombia y Argentina sobre la
preocupación por la detención y
hostigamiento antidemocrático a Castillo
algo que Lima tachó de injerencia
política Aunque lo cierto Es que ante la
negativa del Congreso peruano a convocar
elecciones cada vez más naciones de la
región le están dando la